Finally, the general concept of a cause can be misleading.
To think about the window shuttering, we said it was the ball. It's right.
But, it could also have been the window maker.
If the window maker had not made this particular window
then the window would not have shuttered
and if the house builder had not built this particular house with the window in it
then the window would not have shuttered either.
For a single effect, there can be multiple causes,
and all of these are valid according to our earlier definition.
This is where the concept of an actual cause comes in handy.
An actual cause assumes and changes as little as possible, but it changes the effect.
If we think about the causes we have discussed, a ball shuttering the window
does not change much except for the window.
The window maker not producing the window makes of a larger different
because then we would have the house with one window missing
for quite some time, which would change a lot.
Parts of the house would get very wet for instance,
would be cold or hot depending on the climate.
If the house maker had not built the house, the change would be even bigger.
So, what you want is an actual cause
that assumes and changes as little as possible, which precisely what the ball is in here.
For debbugging the same hole, you want to have a cause
that assumes and changes as little as possible but still produces the effect,
and that's precisely what delta debugging gets you starting with the general cause
the entire input reproduces an actual cause namely a subset of the input
in which everything is relevant for producing the effect.
Here's a quiz. I invoke the GNU compiler, and it crashes.
Which of these are general causes for the failure?
Is it me because no me, no invocation, no crash
or is it Richard Stallman, the founder of the GNU project
because without Stallman no GNU compiler no crash
or is it oxygen, without oxygen, no Richard Stallman, no me, no compiler,
no crash, probably also no world as we know it, no computers,
no electricity, interesting, or finally is it a bug in the compiler
because no bug no crash. Check all that applied.